what does freedom mean to you
freedom is freedom from the mind
the only reason that any human being is
not free is because of his mind
it is the mind which creates his
tortures
it is the mind which creates his
anxieties it is the mind which creates
his conflicts
it is the mind which creates his rules
all that he is confined by all that he
is imprisoned by is the mind not
anything else
when i was young i wanted freedom but i
wanted freedom in the sense of i didn't
want to be trapped in the house i wanted
to be able to live where i wanted i
wanted to be able to make money i wanted
to have a girlfriend i wanted to go to a
place where i could do whatever i wanted
whenever i wanted that's what i wanted
in my mind freedom was just getting away
from physical constraints material
constraints
i got all that stuff i traveled with the
whole world i ate all the food i made
all the money
i got all the things that i wanted in
life
yet the quality of my life did not
change that much the quality of my
moment-to-moment experience didn't
change that much that's because i hadn't
changed that much my internal experience
was still very much the same every time
i got something i wanted the next thing
and wanted the next thing and one of the
next thing
all the same pains and tortures and
miseries were still there maybe some
were better obviously it's better to be
rich than to be poor it's better to be
healthy than to be sick but beyond a
certain point
my baseline level of peace had not
changed that much
then i started making a transition to
what you're talking about realizing that
a lot of these traps were in my mind but
you just jumped all the way you're
saying no it's all from the mind from
the very beginning
yes any freedom that leads to the desire
for more freedom is not freedom if
there's a bleed you don't clean the
tributary vessels you want to look at
the source of the bleed
even if it took someone 30 years
to learn the source of the bleed to
learn the truth about what freedom
really was it would be far more
effective
to begin that journey at this very
second as opposed to doing it piecemeal
because that'll take 900 years it is not
abstract to say that freedom comes from
the mind
what it is is revelatory
the belief is
that anxiety and fears and pain arise
from circumstance
that they arise from other people
as long as that belief is invested
inside of someone
he will spend his life trying to change
circumstance
and that will be a monumental waste of
life and you only get one
so quite frankly there isn't enough time
to go piecemeal
it is far better to not understand than
it is to go piecemeal because then
you're going down a tributary
and that tributary leads to other
tributaries very soon you're way off
course
what we're really talking about here is
that all of the problems that we
struggle with we tend to externalize we
tend to solve them in the external world
and there are certain ones that are
practical in the external world do i
have food do i have shelter those kinds
of things but beyond a certain basic
level a lot of the problems we're trying
to solve in the external world are
actually internal problems and even if
we manage to solve the current
manifestation in the external world the
new problem will just pop up tomorrow in
the external world
everyone's looking for truth
whether they profess to look for truth
or not and the evidence for that is that
everyone is looking for a way out of
their problems
if they weren't then there wouldn't be
14 000 prescriptions on every single
corner from spirituality to self-help
the very fact that those things exist
and the very fact that they are
populated by millions
means that there's an enormous appetite
for relief from problems
this relates back to prescriptions no
human being actually wants to be told
what to do
there's something within a human being
which rejects the idea of being told
what to do quite frankly even when you
do give prescriptions most don't follow
it and they will beg you for years to
get the prescription and when you give
it
they won't do it people look at that and
say see you've been given the
prescription and you didn't follow it
that's your fault no it's not
the fault is believing that that's what
they really wanted it's not
no one wants prescriptions freedom
really is what everyone is looking for
it is just that they've been sold
many lines they've been sold many lies
that it's about meditating and it's
about practicing mindfulness and it's
about doing all these things and none of
those things are wrong
it's all about the question if your
question is i like to feel better for 20
minutes a day it gives me a sense of
peace what can i do there's nothing
wrong with that if the question is
i really want to have peace in my life i
don't want to have problems every single
day my entire life is spent putting out
fires i don't want that anymore that's a
different question
then those prescriptions are invalid for
that
so what is the most important question
i would begin with the one that's most
acute for a given individual now broadly
speaking everyone's problem is problems
anxiety fear concern
worry conflict confusion
this persistent non-specific anxiety is
probably the single most common human
condition that most people are trying to
get away from yeah and the naive version
is i have anxiety because i don't have
enough money so i need to go make more
money then the slightly more
sophisticated version is boy i wish i
could just get over the anxiety of
feeling like i don't have enough because
practically speaking i have enough but i
some reason i'm still anxious so i'd
love to get rid of that anxiety what's
the next level after that it's a more
fundamental level the next level is zero
the idea that someone
should get rid of anxiety is the problem
the problem is not how do i get rid of
anxiety
the way
is actually to learn where anxiety comes
from the people who have conquered
anxiety are the ones who had a clear
understanding of what it is and where it
came from
the solution to a problem is never the
solution it's always the problem
the solution to any problem lies
squarely deep within the problem there
are not two things there's only one
everyone is taught to look for solutions
and they believe that the solution is
independent of the problem
but ingeniously nature has hidden the
problem inside the solution and maybe it
did it because it wanted human beings to
look inside the problem the definition
of the problem is the key
can we go through a specific example
absolutely so in the case of anxiety a
person asks how do i get rid of anxiety
their problem isn't that they have
anxiety the problem is that their
anxiety will never end as long as they
look for a solution to it well if i
don't find a solution then i'm always
going to have anxiety that's correct the
solution is to go backwards is to look
what actually is this anxiety put a name
on it when does it arise
what part of your body does it arise in
in what situations does it arise
know the face of anxiety
not run from it like a boogeyman this is
something that's been solved on an
individual basis
there's no solving it is simply the
understanding the solution to any
problem lies diving deep into the
problem
the answer lies in the anxiety
every single thing that i say is fraught
with peril because the prescription
givers have hijacked the english
language they've already attached an
image to every single word that i use
when i say that you have to look into
the anxiety where that will go is thanks
to the spiritual jargon what they'll say
is i must face my anxiety no no you
don't oh that means that i must watch my
thoughts no no you don't why
because
if you do that you'll be doing so
prescriptively
you'll simply become an automaton who
sits there and watches his thoughts and
then you will say i've watched my
thoughts nothing changed i went into the
anxiety i faced it and nothing changed
the prescription is so subtle that any
attempt to follow it removes you from
the solution
even as you're listening to my words it
isn't about finding out what i'm telling
you to do it is about understanding and
through understanding you can take your
destiny in your own hands and even when
i say that i don't mean to motivate you
by telling you that you can take your
destiny into your own hands forgive me a
thousand apologies i have no interest in
motivating you because if i motivate you
then you will get raw raw and say yes i
too will do that now and you'll fail it
is about very quiet very serious
examination of what actually is being
said never just listen to the words
people send me all these messages saying
what is we mean no prescriptions you see
that's a prescription don't follow
prescriptions it's not about
prescriptions
go into the source of why it was being
said for yourself it is never about the
words it's where they come from
this is what makes these conversations
so difficult
even inspiring other people is hard
because if they're inspired inspiration
doesn't last it fades it's like reading
inspirational quotes or motivational
posters you spike up and then you crash
back down there are times where i've
actually inspired people to go and start
a business and i regret it because if
they're not inspired naturally they're
not going to sustain it for a long
period of time without me around
well it isn't about them i would say
that the only real problem
would not be whether their inspiration
is sustained the real problem would be
if there's a desire to inspire them
that's the non-starter
i desire my part to inspire them that's
right there is no other that's another
one i can't say two words without it
being a whole nother thing
but let's get into it there is no other
i've said life is a single player game
you're just competing against yourself
you're mostly arguing having conflict
with admiring
looking at yourself you're born alone
you die alone how you interpret things
as purely through you how you view the
world is purely through you that's what
i mean by it perhaps you mean something
deeper than that there is no other means
that there's no problem outside of
yourself
and that all conflict is self-conflict
these things in which pain arises from a
circumstance aren't really caused by the
circumstance the circumstance does not
cause pain it reveals it
if someone's intention is that i wanted
to inspire him that's a problem
if the intention is that i didn't care
to inspire him or not then that's not a
problem the problem arises in the
individual because if he tried to
inspire then that came from a place of
ego ego isn't bad but if a person tries
to inspire someone they're really trying
to attain significance in their own mind
that isn't bad either the problem is it
creates problems that's the quote
badness if you did not care whether
you're inspired or not then you'd be
free and freedom isn't good either it's
just that freedom does not create
problems
so a simple example if i'm on twitter
and i send out a tweet
and i do it to get compliments i get a
whole bunch of compliments i like those
i go and i click like on all the
compliments then i get a few insults and
the insults sting and i feel bad it only
takes one insult to cancel out dozens of
compliments mood wise just the way the
human mind is built
after you've done this for a long enough
time you realize that it's because i'm
liking the compliments that the insults
hit me they're hitting some deep fear
that they might be true if someone calls
me a hippopotamus i don't care it's not
real but if someone says oh you're
trying to play fake guru that might hurt
because sometimes i am trying to do that
and so if it reveals something about me
some conflict and some pain that already
existed then it hurts just by
understanding
how
compliments puff me up i can realize
that insults bring me back down
and the freedom comes from realizing
that it's not good or bad i can continue
to make that trade but at least now i'm
aware why i feel bad when i see an
insult all of that would circle back to
do you really want to know
are you the type of individual who
really wants to know and understand
where these things come from because you
have a longing for getting over that for
good one doesn't necessarily have to go
through the understanding it's helpful
to have these kinds of illusions because
that's how we function in society you
could argue society conditioned us that
way so that we could be functional in
normal society but as you understand
more of these things one of the
interesting things i've noticed is as
you peel the onion it has to be done
genuinely otherwise it's not real
otherwise just another pleasure chase
even genuine isn't a rule there's no
need to be genuine that isn't good like
humility it isn't good to be humble
nothing is good yeah if i'm engaging in
self-improvement and i'm feeling good
about it then my mind will eventually be
occupied with this new image of being
the guy who's good at self-improvement
and i've just created another trap for
myself it's all a shell game that's
exactly right
one thing i've noticed is that one of
the ways in which i know that i am
finding truths out is that problem is
solved for good that's exactly right i
don't have to revisit that same problem
again because that problem is solved for
good both my internal state and my
external state quote unquote improve
they change improve is a big word so the
more they change internally i'm quieter
and externally my life is less
complicated
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you